-Hi!
-Hi, bud.
-Hello!
-Stunning, as always.
Thank you for coming back
on our show.
-Thank you for having me.
-Do you remember the last time
we saw each other?
-I do. Do you remember?
-Do you remember?
-But do you remember?
-We were dancing.
-We were dancing to
Justin Bieber.
-We saw "Biebs."
-We saw The Biebs.
-Yeah, we're "Beliebers." And --
-Big-time.
-We were at the Met Gala.
-Yes.
-And Justin Bieber
came out and performed.
He was awesome.
-Yeah.
-And I saw you.
-He had a ski mask on.
-He did.
-Wear a mask, everybody.
-Yes, wear a mask.
-A ski mask.
But whatever. It's close enough.
But we were there,
and I saw you and I go,
"Oh, my God, I have to go over
to Julia and start dancing."
-I was very excited.
I was just like, "Oh, my God."
-Both of us!
-Yeah, we were just like --
-And we were rocking out.
It was so much fun.
-We were like --
-Oh, yeah, we were so excited.
I'm like, "This is a memory."
We created a memory.
Because you know
I'm a giant fan.
I go, "I know and --"
I'm caught up.
No spoilers, but I'm caught up.
Not completely caught up,
but I'm more recent
than I was last time.
-Listen, Jimmy,
you're a busy guy.
You have this every night.
-Thank you, thank you.
-You know, you have a family.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Yeah, I get it.
-Thank you so much. Yeah.
No, but I wanted --
-Give it up for Jimmy!
-No, no, no.
That's not what I --
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, that's not my point.
That's not what I wanted.
My point was, it's so good,
and you were so good.
And everyone in the whole
cast -- Oh, my gosh.
But you --
Everyone I tell "Ozark" --
I go, "Have you seen 'Ozark'?"
If they haven't seen it, I go,
"Watch the first episode
and then call me the next day
and tell me who
Julia Garner is."
And they're like -- Dude,
you just crush it every episode.
You're so good.
-Thank you so much.
That means a lot.
-I know, sorry, yeah.
-No. Are you kidding?
Like, I'm really trying to play
it cool right now,
but I'm actually,
like, terrified.
-Well, there's this scene that
people are talking about online.
I tried not to look at it,
because I don't want
any spoilers.
But, apparently,
you scream in --
-Yes. Which that can be, like,
any scene in "Ozark."
I mean, it's not -- But no.
But this is not
a typical scream. No.
-No, it's not.
-I'm mad.
-You really are.
-I'm very, very angry.
-You're really angry.
-I'm very angry.
-Can we show the video of
the scream at least?
-If you want to stop me,
you're going to have to
[bleep] kill me!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How in the --
How do you do this?
-I was hungry. No, I'm kidding.
[ Laughter ]
-But you are not that person.
This is acting.
-That's acting.
-It is acting.
-I am an actor.
-Yes!
-I look very angry there.
-You are mad!
-Mad!
-The picture --
I can't even hold it.
It shakes.
-Ugh! Jason Bateman!
-I go,
what inspires you for that?
And very interesting answer.
It's art.
-Yes. So, I'm very visual
and I get inspired from
different things, and I really
kind of just wanted
the spirit of, like,
a Caravaggio painting
and the darkness.
And, you know,
I feel like Caravaggio paints
intensity and chaos so well.
So I -- Yes. Yeah.
-I love their
ice-cream cakes, too.
Caravaggio.
-Yes, yes.
And their gelatos, right?
-But your dad is --
-Yes, he's an art teacher.
Yes, an artist, yeah.
-So you know all about this.
-Yeah.
-This is one of the paintings
that inspired you
for the scream.
-Well, I like the chaos.
And, you know, she's obviously
getting, you know, defensive.
I mean, she has snakes as hair.
-Yeah, she's lost her head.
-Yes, she's very mad.
Yes, yes. She's very -- Yes.
-Angry. That's one.
-Yes. And then, yeah,
that's another one.
But, this is not --
You know, not the faces.
I just like the chaos of it.
I kind of just wanted my mind to
feel kind of claustrophobic
like that.
-And so you get into the zone.
You look at these.
-But that wasn't really doing --
So, I got inspired by it,
but there was
still something missing.
And then I realized Mike Tyson
is also another
inspiration for me.
And I really got inspired from
this photo, as well.
-Yeah.
-I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was --
-So -- But here's the thing.
Mike Tyson -- this face could be
in a Caravaggio painting.
I mean, don't you think so?
-Yes, it could be a Caravaggio.
-Yes, a character from
a Caravaggio painting.
So I really got inspired from,
you know, that spirit.
-This was the Holyfield fight.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-He was very mad there, too.
-You think?
I want to talk about
your new show, "Inventing Anna."
By the way, it premieres --
Netflix, February 11th.
It's based on a true story,
a really cool story.
-Yes, it's based off
a Cut article.
And it's about this girl who
scams New York's high society
and pretends to be something
that she's not.
I don't really know --
She's a very complex character.
It's kind of better to watch it.
-I remember reading about her in
the "New York Post" and stuff
and like, "Wait, what happened?
How did she do this?"
-She's a New York poster child,
I feel like, yes.
-She was.
-Yes.
-And, again, a great accent,
a great voice you do with that.
-That was probably the
hardest accent I've ever done.
It was a different mixture
of accents.
So, you know,
this is a girl who is saying
that she's German,
but she's really Russian,
so she's not going to have
a Russian accent.
[ German accent ] So, first,
I had to do, like, a European --
like, a German accent, right?
But, you know, it's very subtle.
It's like, you know, have
a vocal fry at the end of it.
Whatever, right?
[ Russian accent ] And then,
you know, I had to add, like,
some little Russian
for certain words.
It was a very bad
Russian accent.
But then I start to do, like --
This is more of an
Anna Delvey accent.
And then it gets Americanized,
because you know how Americans
kind of add the question
at the end of everything?
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, Europeans
don't do that, right?
-Come on. What just happened?
Yo, that was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That will go in the history
books of how to act right there.
In 10 seconds,
you just did something --
Everyone's face
is melted right now.
Everyone's like, "What?!"
-So, really, my --
I really wanted to make sure
that it was kind of one
of those things,
if she goes back to Europe,
all of her European friends are
like, "You sound so American."
And then all of her friends
here are like,
"Oh, my God,
you sound so European."
-Yeah, exactly.
-Like, OMG. Oh, my God, Anna.
-I know.
-I really like your, like --
-You do? Thank you.
Did you do it for her?
-Yes.
So, I went to go
visit her in jail, and --
-♪ Spoiler alert! ♪
-So, I went to visit her,
and she was like,
"So, uh --
So, how's the shoot going?"
And I said,
"Oh, it's going well."
And, you know,
I'm super-intimidated.
Like, she's Anna Delvey.
And she's like,
"So, um, how you playing me?
How you playing me?"
And I said, "Uh, well..."
She's like,
"Like, what are you doing
with my character, you know?"
And I said --
I didn't know what to do,
so I started mirroring her.
I was like,
"Well, how you playing me?
What you doing
with my character?"
And she was like --
[ Giggles ]
"That's so funny!"
And then I did.
I was like, "Ah-ha!
That's so funny!"
And then the journalist
that wrote the article
was sitting there.
It got really meta.
-Wow!
-And she's fascinating.
I -- Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Julia Garner in
"Inventing Anna."
Take a look at this.
-All men underestimate women.
Even the one
who's supposed to love us.
-Did Alan underestimate you?
Is that why you humiliated him?
-You're so worried about Alan.
Do you seriously think he's in
any danger of losing anything?
I'm the one locked up
for crimes I didn't commit.
I'm the one denied bail.
Every day, men do far worse
things than anything
I've allegedly done,
and what happens to them?
Nothing. No consequences,
no fallout,
and definitely no jail time.
Alan will be fine,
and they'll
probably promote him.
Men fail upwards all the time.
[ Buzz, cell door closes ]
-Oh, that's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Julia Garner, everyone!
"Inventing Anna" premieres
February 11th on Netflix.